beep beep without a phone start of the
ballot it doesn't give you freedom they
just jump on you this white go mr. Huff
is like oh [__] it's your lucky night
[__] of the Joey's in full effect
whether it's get retire boom when you're
not
this is [__] this is what [__] the
Harriet vision of modification
uneducated officers and other parties
have no idea what [__] you spoons
into tonight I don't care what you're
watching 12 with a [__] Obama goodbye
I don't give a [__] if Obama's wife is
showing a little monkey on that [__]
thing tonight
if you ain't going into the church you
wave real tonight and you better have
insurance [__] what's insurance
opportunist but Israel on campus that's
right a [__] ten o'clock oh oh
like green
[Music]
you
oh [__]
cancel Obamacare this is the [__] that
carry Fisher the mother smoked it's over
[__] welcome to the church least
I got Jake [__] quickly with no
bikini on thank God it's my [__] 8:30
it's all over the shop
and that's it and your uncle Joey if
you're under 18 hang up now [__]
because we're going beep beep beep into
the hemispheres tonight say now there
ain't no help ain't nobody can help you
Batman ghostbusters
Superman even Jesus will say let me
think about it and get back to you and
how people going for that [__]
when face is that you have any means any
actor
[Music]
it's that type of party we got Carrie
Fisher all right Pete we got the shrooms
of death police I act and Uncle Joe was
it little [__] you think you're dealing
with car sucks man
we got rocket fuel right here [__] la
Luna one boom please come sit with me
and look at this year right here
[__] this is a new addition for
the church
this is from the son of Cleveland this
guy killed my 18 people this type is
called the Sabbath limited [__] thing
it's got an eyeball it got peep it looks
like [__] what's the name Clinton's
[__] look at this [__] [__] they've
got eyeballs and pulls the cavity
this is what walking to good smoke when
we shot John Lennon ahead we're going
beat the night [__] even [__]
Jimmy Page's in get your [__] together
[__] collect your lucky night
understand me
I've been creeped up all day I was in
Cleveland no sunlight I'm ready now look
into this [__] the black [__] growth
I need a remedy are you kidding me or
what oh [__] I need a rest
this is [__] rocket truck look at its
[__] some of that look at it Johnson
with me you [__] you want to
deal with the [__] best [__] of this
being [__] around tonight everything
was a beautiful day to be alive about a
shout-out to Martin Luther King for
putting this [__] thing together you
something whatever Martin Luther King we
will even be like a medical marijuana
[__] but white people will be
telling the black people then what the
[__] anyway
what's happen you bad [__]
uncle Joey here why not when we say I'm
looking all the time I milady
we only know I pay with the fetters and
you put a piece of THD chop em up then
you pop a little muscle what the [__]
you think you're dealing with
there's a lot of imitations but there's
only one uncle Joey when they make me I
broke the [__] mold young say almost
always like a white party here at P
Diddy white party I got a cheap [__]
ehe face boy needs an itchy [__] for
a parlay of debt didn't fancy and that
is a reward you any of you it is
tremendous
would you leave what the [__] yeah yeah
giving them giving it to mushrooms
detective look at these little mushrooms
[__] Lee right there you're doing just
come on how long does it last
I've never of it think you want to smoke
Beasley shut up smokey bless me to call
many you guys my first time hey pop
those things - god damn it all in one
thank you when I put it I taste like um
if a woman seems like a slave isn't a
schoolboy egg in the woods
come on I feel the same maybe I should
have more yeah hold up take them please
amazing chocolate they taste delicious
but it could be groaning [__] yeah the
cool [__] yeah [__] it legal almost come
on babies oh my god if you're 19 hang up
now [__] I don't need more
information from your parents we're
going deep tonight and we'll pick out
the stars tomorrow we're just starting
this is uh be a hell of a [__]
weekend if you're gonna go to rehab wait
for next week if you're gonna go to
rehab
wait till next week that's all I got to
tell you there's gonna be a good week
you on the chair you like I really have
just yet you get a better deal please
separate short months okay telling me on
the Joey be especially marine wonder
that's right I don't [__] around
that's awesome this time for another
blanket and I'm happy you said so what's
the deal with turns you have to drink
water
I've never done it listen take whatever
you want a drink tequila I'm all ready
to do the killing I'm gonna make that
incision after this I got a feeling you
won't listen that could happen because
you got the couch right there
you have to make no bad decision yes
stranded that's it and that's that
what's going on your beautiful
[__] we didn't forget about you
leaves over here he's like I draw a
piece of hope you got a piece of
chocolate huh because the chocolate
takes a mushroom taste out of your mouth
I'm saying I'll just like sometimes you
got like the ants on to take the [__]
taste out of your mouth and silence sure
you gotta take the end like a mess
really
it's like a [__] mint DeLorean bed
anyway look back for more like [__]
right and I don't know if is 85-84
whatever
listen I've done a thousand things
already tell me what you want from me is
Martin Luther King Day I was doing bong
hits for MLK at 6:00 in the morning with
the Carrie Fisher we jump
I probably rocket fudge why [__] Wow I'm
saying who wants the [__] we were you
doing regular chalk and telling me
regular chocolate normally only regular
chocolate no more
I don't need [__] chocolate chip
cookies no more if those two what a
waste
I'm gonna need a brownie of your
pavement [__] better have some
THC in that goat
I'm saying Lee what's the donate that
job with the young great but there is a
ok see I don't nobody knew read entrance
an tequila's my first time trying
mushrooms I've never done it no it's
like your first time letting somebody's
done continues it's just a couple
minutes in you okay give me that job
give me that [__] chocolate
Jesus Christ we already we got two more
thumbs over your land you sound like
[__] my Conan took it out
don't [__] around here you understand
like the color wait what were you doing
with your life tonight nothing there's
no football there's nothing on TV you
might as well sit back grab a [__]
bong Kate's here leave here the shrooms
are in the [__] you know what do you
want from me what kind of detainment do
you want I'm not here than to [__]
ten you I look like a [__] climbed to
you I'm here to have a conversation with
you to smoke a few bondage with you
leave what are we doing over there we're
sitting there looking at the wall put
some music on here oh [__] [__] about
the Oh real listen what do you got hey
my grill
oh sure yeah yeah it's over she's got oh
[__] your grill is that type of party
plan ladies and gentlemen let's go is
enough work already
what is this here you think that this is
attractive [__] we got the water I was
in it one of the kindest mockingly one
tonight
totally different story
I can't hey guys make sure you go on
Twitter and get on at math later
periscope you see we're late
I never used in to Grandma's let's [__]
around you don't say we're back [__]
that BJ put the [__] music in and
we're going deep I don't know what
you're doing tonight you gonna change
your plans
maybe you cooking blue apron maybe you
looking for Indo Chino suit maybe you
got a dirty [__] and you want to hang
out with Khushi that's in sponsoring the
show tonight
so switch on over that's the savage of
death look at this [__] thing this is
right out of Cleveland is why I love
Cleveland this is why speed big male
chick is that have you world champion
because people make pipes like this and
[__] Cleveland understand me people
don't do this no world peace of savage
why'd you bounce firecrackers it don't
matter
it's Monday night [__] strap on a
pair I'm okay we're gonna fish those
Shroomish you ready for [__] you want me
you want as much a savage or what he
want them and we still got a certain on
a piece of chocolate we're going beep
beep beep let's give you a little piece
will be will you to meet the chocolate
maker meet him right now
don't don't listen to this [__] I'm
gonna [__] really kill you
[__] tonight little Braxton
Santana what are you not so what what
one way about grams don't don't worry
about nothing don't put the questions no
questions here right like I said I found
the Viking in my pocket I ate it I
didn't [__] web and B let them [__]
around the [__] I'm gonna WebMD for my
friends who gives a [__] you you happens
it if you don't die hit the other
that's how we do it around the church or
what's happening now greetings you
[__] of love uncle Joey here full
effect tonight I've been missing for a
few days I wasn't sleeping with those
[__] savages I love that [__] town
next week Tempe Arizona oh [__]
with the great Kate Quigley and Ally
mooses waiting on [__] back down
there that little [__] arable not in
the salmon so if you're not doing that
in Tempe or your uncle or your mother
I'm sure your grandfather lives down
there is a good you dully
it's over what the Tempe improv can't
quickly is taking over [__] Oh
oh [__] how you feeling leave they fell
upon the other one we want smoke the
salmon the other trying to savage
[__] clear clear owns anybody no we
just smoked it up I didn't smoke on the
blinkers and they arrest you I brought
the pipe without smoke no weeding then
they can't stay Dixie is a sin thank you
the carbons right here
while in Judaism kettlebells with steel
club with jumping rope whatever I could
do dog I'm trying
guys I'm [__] trying man talent but
tonight with spinach salad I will be
trouble - mushrooms they add up caloric
one you think that mushrooms oh I feel
emotions I believe I still others I'm
gonna push them up with a goalie how's
the savage if that thing again
it's tremendous made in [__]
Cleveland is a family never whatsoever
oh you gotta give now we're going to
smoke the mushrooms and we crush them up
yeah we do it go that's how you do those
cool oh cool we grind the money yes you
can
gonna say him don't raise them training
line them you grind up the shroom ages
and you mix them with the reap and you
pop that [__]
it's over you know what guys what a
selfie think you deal with some [__]
image was if you want to rock
we're gonna run that's his mother she's
why did your mother she's watching right
now she's watching going here Tony
tomorrow Donita mushroom Glee hold on
because I've been trying to tell you
people you know we got cake quickly it's
Monday she got a lot to tell me a lot to
tell you [__]
what do you want to smoke me you want a
bong how was that fight tremendous it
well with the lightly sure you feel good
you would uncle Joey chocolate oh [__] a
little black magic woman thing at the
party story are you [__] crazy
you must walk down my moon right now
tell uncle Joey is coming into my head
beep why is he doing this command just a
[__] plum I don't want no problems
[Music]
right here coming at you real slow
like a guy with one hand trying to
finger you oh [__]
here we go oh my goodness slow real slow
you're mine digging up that little
[__] stiff and his other hands got
left in Vietnam he's trying to finger
you at the other hand but the hand is
moving real slow it's focused a little
stubby hand is done oh [__]
there we go little Carlos for you
[__] on a Monday night Jesus
cares
oh my goodness here we go with it
with that really
[Music]
fielding I don't imagine legal my
brother the [__] thank you for joining
us we're going deep into the hemisphere
[__] yeah there's a little mushroom a
night I smoked them before so Bentley
was smoking mushrooms like the [__]
Indian tonight you understand me
I need a DP in this [__] watch
how quick originality right now you're
gonna hit a little wasted just to remind
you don't listen man you want to be an
amateur be an amateur you want to roam a
jungle Joey we're grinding up the [__]
weeds that Carrie Fisher smoked with the
mushrooms and spoken that up you can't
beat that you can't beat that type of
party blood [__] edibles Plus
straight-up punch but what do you want
from me people wanted to give a team
when they [__] giving me your pain you
want to [__] around go [__] around with
you get down drinking coffee and [__]
ain't no coffee this [__] and
water in the netting Flint water that's
how we roll fish
that mushroom taste delicious mrs. M
mushroom was goodly we have two more
tales left that's one for you and
actually that's we've left for peaceful
nation either way either the slogan you
pick your voices eat that [__] family
you know nice little dirt worm it's a
little dirt work what don't be the
person eat that [__] funny I'm doing
a nice try though
there you go [__] show me the
money
which is you the [__] think until one
[Music]
we're going live [__] a little
Carlos coming action Monday night get
your head together write your goals be
exploiting push-up you [__] adopt a
hooker [__] support a cat do
something
[Music]
they wake know you've been taught to say
you go slow and [__] tasty commentary
this is what he got was crying this is
like eating ice cream and the guys put
together one hand and what is this that
just pops up like a big boy
oh [__] there's one nothing if you like
it will cut you to pieces
you're hit okay giggle we get a big
piece
[Music]
engine
whatever you want I'm Frank here the
Church of what's happening now where
dreams come true [__]
they get sugar free diabetic free
whatever [__] problem is even if you
even that do with the one hand they got
hands-free there we go
Carlos coming at you again oh [__] god
damn guys I know what finish your
maggots Lepidus from Pink Floyd and sink
the boat come then turn the lights off
and call you in two hours if he was
going out of it leaves over there
drinking water like a camel you don't
give a [__] Jen here we go
are you nuts
don't worry about the work you don't
meet another words they know words he's
saying you don't know they say yes
Spanish hey como vas I have no idea what
leave it means I'm Spanish 53 [__]
years I don't know I don't know I want
to know done so don't bother me with
your [__] offenses here we go Jesus
Christ
[Music]
there's more what I keep in contact
what do you not I hope not to him he
doesn't know I got some scars I say from
1998 these things are like [__]
expired vicodin
you'll be scratching for four [__]
days like these you know I missed you
[__] everything whatever I
don't get to see you for a few days I
got excited I worked myself up my same
[__] you know this is my family this
is the song I put on my ipod what if I
get blood drawn I put this on my iPod
when I looked the other way and by this
point my foot stopped and this [__]
she's talking the needle out she's not
drawing the blood and I just get into
this I just make believe I'm just
[__] back into music and also she
takes the needle and she takes the
rubber off and she holds my arm over and
I know I'm home [__] Raya d60 ticketing
fan fan fan what I'm spent
fan fan fan fan Lily thought wigglin
[Music]
that's right [__] this gold rock
is whatever you want it to be as a
salmon whatever the [__] you wanted to
be coolant [__] because I think it is
kinda stinky that is bang bang bang bang
BAM are you [__] not for one listen no
matter what you put in your body
mushrooms heroin credible reefer always
dehydrate in the family or hydrate
that's what the word cottage you don't
want to dehydrate the sexual base you
see the devil wicked if you're hydrated
that's that won't show up it that devil
don't like water you understand me
here we go here we go are you who shows
up with [__] Abraxas on a Monday
night hope only being downright with you
something like that sir sighs me listen
to this mother [__] dummy load up
some right now being dull Rick you just
come up and you just [__] turn here
we go BAM
MNM NLT listen is the [__] history
lesson I get Abe Lincoln forget us
Washington's got nothing to do with how
you [__] think put this online right
now this will change your life for weeks
you understand this person I don't know
what to tell you although in the act of
hope for don't like a business and all
that's fair review chance for Chinese
dude showed up with sparrows right now
[__] it me oh my god [__] spareribs
right now with some yellow bucket that's
[__] stood don't you [__] to hit
you this position combination this is
this is it right here
hey those are your muscles Jenna knows
the door show our wagon this party
started come I'm happy that you came to
the free church party so you know what
type of party it is there's no
misunderstanding if you're Christian
hang up now they think of my dad for you
cake quickly walks in the room if I
huncle show it becomes already - I'm
just just just like that of your
Christian this is not for you says if
Disney movie on Excel something's on
that you can watch it your family your
something down yo the initiation life
baby listen Santana this will make you
think that [__] Bibles roll out the
window you understand if you're a
Scientologist put this [__] our minds
and this is it after this you who wants
to see Marshall you got Santana Kevin
family
made them really angry fun
[Music]
yeah it wasn't why you have to switch it
up a little bit I just had a brain fart
just [__] it and put this on right now
to really kick this [__] off do
a couple more bunk let's get your bunk
ready put some ice cubes in we filled up
the freezer thank you here you go my
life you guys be hydrating [__]
if not the double shows up quicken these
ever showed up one of my all-time
favorite now is making steady that'd be
fifty foods first [__] our planet
Claire rock lobster you need the
quaalude and you'll [__] shoot
yourself after that what's the story
nice part that body is a sterile look at
me like I'm a [__] let's do this [__]
this also got some muscle juice and [__]
[Music]
smoking you never sure here we go so
much when kick it in right now
[__]
just when you thought would say just
when you thought it would be a ho-hum
week
uncle Joey shows up supplying June cake
with food on clock why are these
[__] shimano my [__]
and that is Monday night nobody has it
will follow on Thursdays swiss-italian
Savage is the amateur pianist
you wanna rock with the bathroom Led
Zeppelin for the other Monday we go
seven o'clock in one day right looks
like that I don't know no no no no I
left back in the seventh grade at a Jean
King real midnight motion I don't look
this way to listen
youtube.com glassy glass show we did
youtube.com slash scene where Joey is
give a sense 15 [__] minutes get your
head together I don't care if you got to
drive over to Grandma's and steal a
valium and come back get your head
together you understand me
she came up Lana Claire oh [__] I know
she came from there are you [__]
listen get your life together yo what's
gonna steer you wrong
if I say that goes is that the [__]
gold is day you understand me
that does that my mother [__] I am with
you guys I love you [__] without
you I'd be it [__] behind four bars
right now making jokes I'll cookie I
love you [__] [__] barley will
see you 15 minutes or Rock grandma